فقال ستيفان دو جاريكا المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده ان برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي يتوقع ان يبداوا ان يبدا
توزيع المواد الغذائيه في الولايات ولايات
الجضارف والجزيره وكسلا والنيل الابيض في
الايام المقبله
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه رفع بشكل فوري
التعليق المؤقت لعملياته من المتوقع ان
يبدا توزيع المواد الغذائيه في ولايات
القضارف والجزيره وكسلا والنيل الابيض في
الايام المقبله وكما تعلمون تم التعليق
العمليات بعد الوفاه الماساويه بثلاثه من
اعضاء فريق برنامج الاغذيه العالمي في
الخامس عشر ابريل وحيثما يسمح الوضع
الامني بما في ذلك في الشرق السودان يواصل
شركائنا عملياتهم وعلى راسها تقديم
الخدمات الصحيه والاغذيه
وا
ضافت المتحده للشؤون اللاجئين تخطط
لاستقبال ما يصل الى 800 الف شخص قد يفرون
من القتال في السودان الى الدول السبع
المجاوره
جنسي تخطط المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده
للشؤون اللاجئين بالتشاور مع الحكومات
والشركاء لاستقبال ما يصل الى 800 الف شخص
قد يفرون من القتال في السودان الى الدول
السبع المجاوره دون حل سريع للازمه سنستمر
في رؤيه المزيد من الاشخاص يجبرون على
الفرار بحثا عن الامان والمساعده
الانسانيه احدث الارقام الصادره عن الفرق
الموجوده على الارض تؤكد وصول ثلاثه
وسبعين الف شخص الى الدول المجاوره